senator senator you have some time for a
quick interview
i'm on my way to a meeting it'll just be
a few minutes
what do you have any comments on the
irregularities in the mail in voting i
don't think there aren't any
think the republicans knew that
they knew it when they were advocating
mail and voting this entire thing is a
spectacle
what do you think about the debate so
far i think this
administration does not treat any of our
democratic process with dignity
and respect okay this is a
vulgar and crass administration this is
ridiculous
america is built on customs traditions
rituals it's built on respect for
institutions
this administration has none of it do
you think the president's going to
accept the results of the election
well we're actually going to discuss
that right now that's you you caught me
on my way to a meeting to discuss just
that what what is the meeting where are
you going
it's an election year and there's a lot
of interested parties and what we're
trying to do is safeguard
a democracy of the people for the people
by the people
that's what we're doing how did you find
me i was telling you for a little bit
clever boy huh yeah why don't you come
cover it really
come cover the meeting yeah i'd love to
come cover the meeting absolutely
i think it's a good idea i think so too
can you want to get some footage right
yeah
please you're gonna meet a lot of
interesting people thank you so much